el conflicto entre la junta militar de
mianmar y los civiles opositores sigue
vivo con represión militar prácticamente
a diario cientos de muertos y miles de
arrestados desde el golpe del 1 de
febrero ahora el país asiático enfrenta
una intensificación de la violencia algo
de lo que naciones unidas advirtió y
calificó como una catástrofe de los
derechos humanos vino al sur y las
detenciones masivas de activistas
periodistas y opositores al régimen han
continuado en todo el país y fuentes
fiables indican que al menos cuatro mil
804 personas permanecen detenidas
arbitrariamente la alta comisionada
también está profundamente preocupada
por los informes de tortura detenidos y
castigos colectivos a los familiares de
los detenidos
cuatro meses después del golpe los
enfrentamientos se han recrudecido en
varias regiones del país como calle a
chin kachin y ante los abusos de fuerza
de los militares acusados incluso de
utilizar a civiles como escudos humanos
y de torturar a detenidos algunos
ciudadanos están entrenando para
conformar las
las fuerzas de defensa además alrededor
de 800 militares birmanos han desertado
en su mayoría para unirse al movimiento
de desobediencia civil por su parte la
junta sigue centrada en tumbar a los
símbolos de la resistencia como la líder
anza en su lucha contra la que han
interpuesto denuncias por delitos de
corrupción y abuso de poder ahora ella
tiene un juicio previsto para el lunes a
pesar de sus intentos los militares no
han conseguido controlar el país con un
conflicto que ha dejado a cientos de
miles de desplazados